what's up alex how can i help so over
the years i have become more and more of
an introvert
and i don't know if it's like who i am
and just to be okay with it or if it's
something i'm doing as like a
self-preservation tool
what do you think it's i
bounce back and forth because they're i
find myself wanting to go out with
people
and hang out and do things and also find
myself like i'd rather go home and just
sit with my dog
so do they have to be mutually exclusive
can you be doing both
well a lot of times it's because i go
out like with my friends at church
when i do go out so i can't really bring
my puppy to church
no so what i'm saying is is it mutually
exclusive can you
becoming a little more introverted as
you get older and wiser and
tired or more exhausted and
you're also choosing to do different
things with your life withdrawing a
little bit just because it's easier
can you be doing both of those things
i'd say that's a possibility um so
i know what is it about this stuff
that's that's making you
uncomfortable like why the call
because like i find myself i want to
create a community uh with people
especially with this past
year who's like really kind of
reinforced it with me yeah
and getting people together and just
loving everyone despite our
differences on whatever the case may be
and but
it's like sometimes it's like okay you
guys will be a community and i'm gonna
go home and not be a part of it anymore
go to bed that's right i'm gonna talk
about it and then i'm gonna go to sleep
that's right i'm a i'm a instagram
social justice warrior
right we're going to all get together
and party and we're all going to have
our differences in
good night right exactly hey i've i've
got a very similar
predisposition alex um
so anytime somebody tells me they want
to develop a community
with an outcome attached to it my first
thought is that community is probably
going to fail
okay if somebody tells me i want to
develop a community because i want to
get out there i want to meet new people
i want the experience of hanging out i
know that it's going to
help me it's going to help me be well
it's going to help me
in all sorts of physical ways and
and mental ways and and physiological
ways
if somebody tells me that awesome it's
gonna have some legs on it
if somebody says i wanna get a group of
people together because we're gonna
man that's probably gonna run out of gas
it'll either run out of gas 30 years
from now when you
quit the group or fall down dead or just
going to run out of gas because you're
going to be propping it up because
it's outcome based right yeah
so i would rather you say i just want to
get a group of people because
i like being with them here's a here's a
rule i had to make for myself
i love love love love hanging out with
people it's my favorite things in the
world to do
and i'm an introvert i like i i have i
like to withdraw
when i get exhausted i would draw i like
going home and just sitting with my kids
and the chickens and
being out in the moon right so i have a
rule
that if there's something going on that
i know i would love to do
and my first thought is i just want to
go home and go to bed
i have to go so if i'm leaving work and
somebody texts and says hey we're
getting the fights tomorrow um
are you coming and my first thought is
dude i just want to go to bed
my rule is i gotta go because i know
it's the right thing for me
i've never gone to the fights with good
friends that i love and love being
around
or gone to some wacky pool hall to watch
the fights and it's like
this thing may go down at any moment
i've never done that and regretted it
not one time
i have gone home and gone to bed i don't
necessarily regret it but i miss those
that community right
and for me if you're like me alex if i
do it once
and i'll do it again i'll do it again
suddenly i'll look up and it'll be a
month and i haven't hung out with
anybody
yeah is that is that you oh yeah
that's been part of the challenge is
getting back into society because i went
through a really hard breakup and
there you go i completely withdrew from
everybody and everything and then
when i picked my head up everyone was
kind of dispersed and gone
there you go so here's what i want to
challenge you with
we don't talk use this word very often
with relationships because it sounds
gross
but it is what it is and that's where
we're at and that's the word i'm going
to use
as as um the world opens back
up in these wonky fits and starts and
opens and shuts and all that stuff as it
does that
as it's gonna do and friends who have
scattered and found new friends and i
talked to somebody this morning on the
radio that just went got married
i mean people have just done things
during this season
right yeah as it comes back together
i want you to keep this word in your
head i'm gonna practice
friendship again i'm going to practice
i'm going to stumble through this i'm
going to fail i'm going to be awkward
i'm going to be weird i'm going to get a
group of people together and as soon as
they all show up i'm going to think
i don't want to be here i want to be at
home but i'm going to stay
i'm gonna i'm gonna make jokes i'm gonna
laugh and also
if i get a group of people together and
i just cannot go today i'm gonna call
them back hey guys i'm
super sorry i know i set this up i can't
make it today i'll be there next time
and they'll all text me like ooh you're
such a lit you're so lame you want a
loser you're an idiot i'd be like i know
i'm an idiot
it's cool shake it off i'll be there
next time and if they're your if they're
your gang they'll be there next time and
they'll make fun of you hey remember the
last time you didn't show up
yeah that was super lame i just didn't
have it man and then we're gonna go
again
and then we're gonna go watch the fights
we're gonna go watch the movie we're
gonna go sing the songs or whatever it
is we're gonna do
but here's the thing it's not gonna be
something you can just waltz and sprint
back into especially brother you're
coming off some heartbreak
right yeah the last big relationship you
had hurt you so your brain's got a
vested interest in keeping you away from
other people because they hurt
and your body has a vested interest in
you getting around people because that's
the only way to be well
okay does that make sense no it does it
makes perfect sense i
just it's like you said putting it back
into practice and
hey being an introvert dude is awesome
it's annoying too sometimes i wish i
could go out and be like hey everybody
woohoo sometimes i just don't have it
and so i go and i hang out and i have a
few
deep conversations in the corner i go
for an hour and then i leave
but there's something about that ritual
that practice that showing up and that's
showing up and that showing up and then
sometimes i go man and the wheels come
off and we
laugh and i'm loud and i'm silly and
ridiculous
and they're loud and they're like dude
you are an idiot and we all have a good
time and then we get up and do it again
the next time
but it's a practice and i want to
encourage you
to when you have those moments like hey
all the guys all the girls everybody's
getting together
i think i was going to go sit with my
dog it sounds like you're telling me you
want to be
out with your buddies but you have that
pool to go be with your dog
go be with your buddies even when it's
uncomfortable be the first guy to say
this is super weird i'd rather be
hanging out with my pet but i knew i
should come
be that guy right yeah but go first
okay go first if nothing else go first
and have your friends over to your
place tell everybody bring whatever
weird leftover gizmo they've gotten
their
meal they've got in their uh kitchen
bring them over dude
and start small okay
that sounds feasible hey it super is and
it's gonna be weird
and be the first guy to be like well i
was awkward
and appoint somebody next time we're
hanging out at your house because i just
screwed this up
and listen man you're still good you're
still alex from from
from los angeles california right
yeah you're still going to be good
definitely you're still worth hanging
out you're still with having a community
so will you will you commit to america
and by america i mean like 18 listeners
will you admit to america or commit that
you're going to get a gang you're going
to get together with some friends this
weekend
yes i will you that's awesome alex good
for you brother
thank you so much for the call everybody
is going to be feeling weird in this
deal i saw uh
the the ufc's the the the ufc that's
going to florida that's the first
sporting event back it is
every i get sold out in eight seconds
like whatever it is like
fast to sell in history whatever there's
gonna be those people
i am sprinting back as fast as i can i'm
throwing my mask in the air like a
like a like a diet coke commercial and
i'm just gonna be running in slow-mo to
the the next
thing and there's going to be those who
are like i'm going out and they open the
front door and they're like nope and
they're shutting the door back
everybody's going to be graceful with
one another there is no right or wrong
way to do this
other than to remember you gotta have
community however weird and wonky that
looks for you
and you gotta practice that community
because we don't know what we're doing
right now
we're gonna stumble and trip and fall
and screw up and be idiots and be silly
and say the wrong things
and we're gonna have to forgive and be
graceful and then go again and go again
and go again
and alex you're a brave bold man for
giving me a shout i appreciate it
go get them go get them go get them